self introduction okay
um hi everyone my name is James Andrews
I'm 33 years old and I'm from Portland
Oregon in the United States yeah yeah
I'm super excited to be here uh of
course I've had Japanese food back in
Portland many times but I've never had
the real thing here in Japan so I'm
really looking forward to it yup yeah
I'm super hungry I mean I skip breakfast
just like you said so oh I'm not
supposed to say that okay this
restaurant is super fancy it feels like
we're in a five-star hotel or something
I can't believe oh I think this might be
it okay here it comes
okay and
oh my gosh this looks Inc oh
sorry are these clams
yeah oh I'm super sorry yeah these are
clams I can't I don't know like if
they're touching even if they're all
take two kumikoson has ordered me a new
dish based on my likes my preferences
and my allergies and we're kind of
waiting for that right now my
imagination is just sort of going crazy
you know I'm thinking about how do they
make food in Ghibli movies look better
than actual food you know okay we're
just oh okay here it comes
oh I'm so excited I can't wait to see
what it is
oh oh uh
sorry
isn't this just fried chicken oh okay
Kara age
Fried Chicken okay so Kumiko Sonos told
me that this is fried chicken but it's
prepared in a way that's completely
different from what I'm used to back
home I'm gonna try it right now I'm
super excited
okay here we go hmm
um sorry it's hot yeah that is different
than what I'm used to back home and
really really good it's almost as good
as the Fried Chicken I've had in Korea
what's wrong I can't oh take three so
Kumiko swan has ordered me a third dish
she says I need to try something that's
uh truly Japanese so uh we're waiting
for that right now and once again my
imagination is just sort of going crazy
you know I'm thinking about all those
beautiful shots I saw in that movie
um Giro Dreams of Sushi and I have
another bite of the chicken I'm really
okay sorry oh actually I think this
might be it
finally
okay here we go
looks like
oh
[Music]
uh sorry what is this
fermented soybeans
okay
um
oh I know what this is this is the uh
what do you say Japanese
dokiri right I've seen a lot of
no
I'm supposed to eat
but no not if it tastes like what it
smells like yeah I I know what I'm very
grateful for that maybe we should just
like change restaurants or go to a
McDonald's but you said I should give my
raw reaction why are you so yeah sure
hey everyone my name is Thomas Jaffe I'm
31 years old and I'm from the United
States